Chris Cornell's daughter honors her late  father with a touching performance it's  an honor to perform this for my dad in  Chester on Friday One Republic took the  stage to pay tribute to the late Chester  Bennington and Chris Cornell on Good  Morning America the band was joined by  Cornell's 12 year old daughter Toni for  a performance of Leonard Cohen's  Hallelujah the same song Bennington  performed at Cornell's funeral in May  she tied you to a kitchen chair she  broke your throne and she cut your head  see  [Music]  the Soundgarden frontman and linkin park  singer were close friends before their  deaths Linkin Park was originally  scheduled to perform on the morning show  but One Republic filled in after the  band cancelled their tour and concert  dates  Bennington was found dead from an  apparent suicide at the age of 41 on  July 20th the same day that would have  been Cornell's 53rd birthday  [Music]  [Music]